this is a production of Cornell
University so we may get a visitor which
will be really cool for all of us and to
get on tape to show her when she's all
grown up someday yeah yeah right now
Sesame Street's are entertained mind one
of the biggest challenges all you guys
have in addition to all the other
challenges is trying to explain at the
young people what's going on yeah yeah
she's 20 months oh yeah used to these
webinars actually so you used to be like
the computers like the forbidden fruit
right but now it seems like she's
getting more used to so maybe not quite
as interesting thanks for taking the
time so again here we are I don't know
any other way to say this I've been
doing this this our sixth one now in two
weeks
we do one for golf one for lawn and and
one lawn and grounds and one for sports
and each one keeps evolving the
information keeps changing it turns out
it wounds up winds up being a really
good thing to do and again for me to
remind you of the value of the safety
right we have to you know all everything
we're doing here is keeping each other
safe the reason we're in this position
is we want to keep each other safe and
so what I'm going to talk about is sort
of strategic ways to think about taking
care of your lawn and grounds and and
how if you're going to work right if
you're going to work what's essential
how do you determine it and I would be
remiss again if I didn't say we're doing
this to keep people safe and also when
we work we have to keep people safe so
the question that came up and I thought
happened yesterday and this is an update
from yesterday it was updated apparently
this morning at 6:00 a.m. that
horticultural wall deemed non-essential
landscaping for maintenance and pest
control purposes has been designated as
essential so I'm not an interpreter of
these
things right we could parse this out but
it seems to me that this provides an
argument that law and landscape
professionals can work ok so let me
leave it at that that's what the
government says as of today there's the
date I'd encourage you to stay up to
date at the Agra Markets website of
course we have the disaster Education
Network through Cooperative Extension
that I talked about last week and you
can watch the video of last week and
learn more about that all right well if
you're gonna work right what does the
lawn and landscape industry say well the
lawn or landscape industry national
association of landscape professionals
just last week a beginning of this week
published guidelines and guidance for
business operations during this time and
as it should it begins with talking
about how you keep your people safe and
there's a lot of good resources for this
right I would encourage you if you're a
manager of the business running a
business a foreman for a crew you know
overseeing workers overseeing employees
even if you are an employee everybody
should be mindful of these guidance
documents everybody should be mindful of
what's going on in society as we know it
on our planet is completely altered now
for something we cannot see that
confuses us and so it requires us to be
as specific as possible about how to be
safe and that's why I think these kinds
of industry-wide guidance documents are
good places for everybody to start when
they're trying to keep people safe now
what's going to happen is not everyone's
going to be feeling comfortable coming
to work nuts you might have a positive
on your crew and if you haven't split up
your crews and you have common meeting
places and you haven't demonstrated that
that these people aren't infected
there's going to be lots of quarantines
and removals for periods of time until
testing becomes more common the golf
course superintendents of America have
put together what I think is one of
these emergency business documents I
didn't see it in others this is the one
I still think is a good place but you
have to have a response plan
right what are you doing with your
workers right if you're just going out
and taking a couple of wipes and wiping
things down hoping for the best I would
not suggest hope as a viable strategy
I just don't think hope is going to be a
viable strategy so I think having a plan
is always better so I think there's lots
of resources and additional burdens that
a lot of managers have in lawn and
landscape crews because unlike Dolf and
unlike sports lawn and grounds
management is a dispersed operation
you're dispersing people into a
community into a county across state
lines driving trucks right I mean we're
talking about a much more complicated
situation as we come to understand
community spread it as virus and how
rapidly things are going to get shut
down if we don't take better care and
follow some of these principles so I
think that's the end of my soapbox for
that once you're going to decide what
you're going to do right again National
Association landscape professionals have
done a nice job here and saying what's
essential right landscape professionals
here's what we do this is what we do
with perform regular maintenance prune
to control weeds essential treatments to
reduce the spread of deadly diseases
ticks and fleas I'm going to talk a
little bit about that right so it's very
clear if you look at these documents
what can be deemed essential now I
really like it if you haven't been to
this website let me encourage you to do
it this one of the other things I mean
every industry's got to do it right
because we're managing our landscapes
for people having a strategy for
communicating with customers during this
time it's really important right then I
don't want to come out and talk to you
they may have some confusion about it
right and there's going to be challenges
you're going to face around this so I'd
encourage you to go to the National
Association of landscape professionals
there's an article in there just
published a couple of days ago really
good tips and tidbits from people in the
field this is what we need more of you
guys as a room are some of the most
adaptive problem-solving people I know
I mean I think sometimes we get into
ruts we do things all the time but I
really see great responsiveness to
what's happened I hope we keep up
communicate with clients communicate
with workers as well because you may see
a reduction in your workforce over time
right you may see people becoming
uncomfortable coming to work so having
these abilities to have these
conversations both with your clients
that their concerns about whether
they're going to be able to keep up the
service and are you gonna do
enhancements or are you doing
maintenance what's it going to look like
if you start installing a landscape
during a pandemic I think these kinds of
things are strategizing I think maybe it
comes down to maintenance and then it
comes down to okay what am I gonna do on
my lawn and then it comes down to what's
going on well in my mind for most of you
if I was a lawn care professional
I'd be looking at 55 degrees soil
temperature if my soil is at 55 degrees
soil temperature I know things are
beginning in earnest as far as my lawns
waking up and getting going and I'm
getting growth where I've really got to
think about it so if you use that as a
measure you know in the New York
metropolitan area that where Matt is
we're pretty close
still in the low fifties and you get
wide variety of measurements you can see
as you get further north the soils are
upper 30s to upper 40s all right now air
temperature wise we use growing degree
days right if you're not familiar with
growing degree days you can go to our
forecast website it's basically a way of
seeing how we lay Heat and how it
advances so well in general much
following like it's been for the last
couple of growing seasons we're ahead of
normal to the south so those of you in
New York State Long Island out where
Matt is you're a little bit ahead of
normal and you see it's much ahead of
normal as you get further south and then
all the white space is well you know we
haven't accumulated enough to even know
how far we are behind yet but there's
some sense we're behind and so you see
in Hudson Valley still 21 to 14 days
behind in some areas and what is
projected to happen going forward is
that at least for the next few
days not much enhancement we've got some
cool weather a little bit of rain Dan
some dry weather we are expecting some
above normal temperatures next week so
we will see some advancement in the
coming week in the landscape especially
as you move to the south alright so
again where to start first I tell you if
you're not thinking about raising your
mowing Heights on your customers I
really believe you're making a mistake
I simply do not see any argument for not
raising the mowing height I'm going to
talk about ticks in a second and I don't
know again if Jo Ellen is here but we
wanted to talk about weeds today we
talked about ticks last week you can
watch that videotape but right now there
isn't any evidence we see any more or
less ticks and grass that's mowed higher
there's no evidence we're going to see
anything more or less we don't have any
data to indicate that we have some data
indicate that regular mowing staying
away from the woodlot edges works for
keeping pigs down so we do have some
piece of information that some mowing
keeps the ticks down we'll talk about
ticks more but for sure to reduce the
amount of time you gotta mow the first
thing you do is raise the height I would
tell you there isn't a long I can think
of in the Northeast that can it can't
tolerate go on a four inches can't
tolerate going to four inches now we can
have some arguments about some
exceptions but in general I don't think
you should start mowing until it's
almost six inches so I think we're a
long way from six inches now we can
debate that so how is it growing right
now well we've got average air
temperatures in the upper 40s to low 50s
and if you look at this you're still
only at about 50% of how much growth you
can get and in general you shouldn't be
out there slinging fertilizer I would
not necessarily be out there slinging
fertilizer unless dr. Elmore is gonna
tell me in a minute a thin lawn and you
don't want to put a pree down maybe a
fertilizer could help a thin lawn rather
than putting a pre-emergent down we'll
have that conversation in a minute
but let me wrap up by talking about
ticks a recent paper was brought to our
attention here at Cornell that indicated
leaf litter building up along
the edges of the landscape something
like this now this is funny I got a
picture pulled it off the internet about
this pollinator habitat but this kind of
leaf litter along the edge there in this
study has been shown to have a higher
population of the black legged ticks
really a very interesting leaf paper
associated with public health in my mind
in some ways this study did not include
mulch mowing ugh I wish they would have
included much mulling it didn't it just
had removal and composting removal and
disposal or leaving them there and
leaving them there in a situation like
this always had a higher percentage
about 13 to 15 percent higher especially
along the edge where the habitat was
very favorable all right let me wrap up
and make our transition make a
transition to bring a mat in here first
off you know I haven't see I've seen
reports and seeing some chickweed
flowering the winter annuals beginning
to flower right along the curbside right
along the curbside but only where the
heat is building up along the edge am i
seeing it advanced the most rapidly and
I'm also not seeing much germination you
had a crabgrass and I don't know we've
got the soil temperatures Matt but now I
wonder I'm gonna stop sharing my screen
so we can see you let's start with a
simple conversation of that I brought up
earlier one of the questions landscape
professionals might be asking at this
time is well I don't want to get out put
my pre I put out my weed and feed and
I'm sure you know the mantra and the
dance of the weeded feed that happens so
my question to you is would you
recommend maybe a little nitrogen if
you've got a thin law and hold off on
the pre because it still feels early
where where are you at as you for using
nitrogen as an alternative to getting
the pre out earlier as a complete
alternative I mean I guess back up I
agree with you that it's a little early
you know as you go farther north I think
you know you saw you showed those soil
temperatures I think what we're waiting
on at least in this region is we're
waiting on a few warm days in a row you
know 75 degrees 80 degrees we haven't
really had that we got a little bit of a
tease that in the in early March and
that brought the forsythia to full bloom
so that's our indicator for crabgrass
but or at least for getting your
pre-emergence out but I agree if we stay
in this cool weather pattern it's not
going to germinate for a while I've I've
only seen a little bit of crabgrass
germinating inside box you know where it
gets warm I think again we're waiting
for warm temperature so you're right if
now's a good time to put out nitrogen
you could definitely do that and wait
for your you're free you know maybe for
some of you farther north it might be
three to four weeks I guess it depends
on though the logistics of your business
and you know what we're doing right if
you don't think you're gonna be able to
get back to a lawn for six weeks or so
you might want to go ahead and apply if
you're using a pendimethalin or a pro
diamine product if you've got to fire
cream you've got more flexibility there
so especially if you're using desire
pure like you said Frank you might be
able to wait and put some nitrogen out
now and that is gonna be really
important to get that lawn you know
dense to try to come out compete weeds
we see it all the time you know it's
probably a dense lungs just as powerful
as any herbicide and then to really need
to work together if you've got a thin
lon
you know the herbicides really aren't
built to hold up over an entire season
with the thin one yeah they're gonna get
you so far but you really do need that
density so if you if now is a good time
to start building that density if you've
got some active growth I would agree it
nitrogen is going to be a useful thing
so I guess delaying that pre is there's
really maybe up to again logistics of
your business and where you are you know
if you're up in New England where soil
temperatures are still 30 we've got
plenty of time again here in Jersey I
think we're waiting on a few warm days
in a row okay so there's there's two
things on my mind is the one thing that
well you know well sounds like they're
saying I could just go out with weeded
feed now because well Rossi says I need
a little and I might be a little bit
early but what if it gets bad
in new york metro area and they figure
out they gotta shut down they gotta keep
everybody off or worse I got one guy I
need 15 guys to make applications yeah
yeah how serious of we're gonna get a
front row seat then what happens when we
don't use pre-emergent herbicides give
me a worst-case scenario let's say we
couldn't get out there let's say they
shut down mid next week and said you
can't get out yeah or you don't have the
workforce and you can't get out for a
month what's it gonna look like when we
get back into that landscape that if
it's a month I mean you know we'll have
some weeds that start to emerge but we
still have a chance to maybe use some
post emergence herbicides or those kind
of things to to control and if you know
we get shut out and it's and then we
can't get back to July that could be a
problem where yeah there's gonna be
there's gonna be a lot of weeds so I
guess if we do get shut out you know
trying to communicate with your
customers that you know here's what to
expect and but here's our plan for
whenever we get back in business what
we're gonna do and you know you're gonna
have to you know that's like that the
density thing you mentioned is going to
be important for if we get into a
situation where we can't get get onto
these properties and that's gonna
definitely help in the summer but the
reality is it you know nitrogen alone
probably isn't gonna cut it
for everyone you know there's if if we
get shut out there's gonna be weeds that
come up and if it depending on how long
this goes you know it might make it
tougher to control things like crabgrass
especially if it goes on too long if
it's just a couple months you know you
know into June crabgrass can be
controlled pretty easily if it's small
but once it really gets big that's when
you get behind the eight-ball I guess
you could say and it's hard so what
about my hire we do get the industry say
listen I was like three Rossi says for I
what the hell I only got a few guys I
can stripe up the lawn at four and I
have listen Matt I'm a very a great hope
that adaptations people make now to see
what's minimal and essential yeah sticks
and becomes part of what we
I'm really pushing hey get it up to four
inches oh yeah all right now I am I
starting to get to the point where now
you're feeling better if I gotta wait
longer by those two adaptations for sure
yeah absolutely so yeah I mean
increasing the mowing Heights gonna
reduce crabgrass pressure and good
fertilizer fertilization practices will
- so yeah I mean hopefully you know
maybe these are some of these customers
could be convinced that hey maybe this
four-inch mowing ID isn't so bad I don't
you know I don't have as many weeds and
that research has been done you know to
show that crabgrass infestations are not
as bad if you increase the mowing right
especially if you can get to four inches
so it's reassure and I don't delay the
crabgrass germination a little bit -
it'll keep that soil temperature cooler
so that any anything to get turf density
how to cut all good so I've got a
question that intersects you know we're
talking about the higher mowing height
and so that can give you some advantages
with crabgrass control you know a lot of
people are going to be trying to get out
here especially in the northern areas of
New York to clean up so there's all this
leaf litter around the edges of the lawn
we just talked about ticks being a more
prevalent in the edges where there's
leaf litter is would it be too crazy to
think okay we've got this leaf litter
around maybe we throw it in the lawn and
mulch it up a little bit to provide some
weed control I know in the fall that's
kind of a good strategies you can mulch
those leaves into the lawn and that kind
of shades out the under canopy in the
spring is that an option for people who
maybe want to do a two for one thing I
don't want to remove all this debris I
think so I'm not aware of any research
specifically addressing that maybe I'm
just not missing something but but I
think it definitely makes sense I mean
there is some work to show that
returning clipping so long can reduce
crabgrass and the theory is that it's
not only the nutrients are returning but
actually those clippings are gonna
provide some light layer mulch
shade shade that soil from you know
crabgrass see things that need light to
germinate so that in theory I think
that's a great idea and maybe something
to adopt I guess the only thing to be
careful with would be you know if you
put out too much leaf litter that's
gonna tie up a bunch of nitrogen
for that balance strikes it's a little
bit outside of my area of expertise but
that would be the only thing maybe you
want to complement it with a nitrogen
fertilizer application but yeah I think
that would be a good adaptation for
these times you know old Michigan State
work that showed I think Ron Calhoun did
it he did the maple and oak leaf thing
they found that some of the leaves
reduced dandelion populations the way
they were doing mulching work they also
found that longtime mulching the leaves
into the lawn they didn't really change
soil properties in any meaningful way
but I do think this is important you
know you've shown that I wonder I know
we've wondered about this out loud that
there is some value to doing some
smothering of that surface right you
remember we had this question about Bank
grass and thatch and and I'm wondering
you know every year when we go out with
this pre I really come to believe that
that tree is if you don't disturb the
ground the only thing that pre is really
doing is preventing last year's C drain
from reestablishing because it seems to
me over the season the seed gets buried
to a certain extent what do you think
yeah so you're talking about I mean I
agree that trees are gonna last your
seed or what those fries are gonna
inhibit you're talking about maybe seeds
that get deposited on the lawn and in
like the summer or so every year so the
pre-emergence are dealing with the seed
rain from last year right yeah yep and
they're gonna hold up for 6-8 weeks and
then once you get to July the pre is not
really there anymore probably unless
you're making split applications or
doing something like that have you seen
the pressure bad enough lately to need
split applications yeah I mean we have
you know Summer 2018 was bad you know it
was hot and rainy I think it really I I
just tell people it depends on you know
your history you know if you've got a
really dense long and you've never had
any problems with a single application
you know you don't really I wouldn't
necessarily adopt a split application
program
but if you have found you know for
example in 2018 or maybe even last
summer that you know your pre wasn't
holding up you might want to think about
that split application and also you know
try to improve so you know the
conditions for the turf to grow to it
just depends especially in the
mid-atlantic I think they're gonna need
more split applications you know as you
get farther north the season shorter I
don't know what kind of a season we're
in for you know it looked like it could
be a long one but now it's pretty I
think temperatures are more normal
so listen let me ask you one more
question and it will go to some listener
questions one of the reasons I think a
lot of people think in their freezer
failing is now we're getting goose grass
chi Linga grass paw which would be Alice
I think we are now you know you have
really sounded the warning here to me at
least from a goose grass perspective and
I studied annual grassy weeds enough to
have it in the back of my mind and what
your what you started to draw my
attention to last year when we visited
now I see we're still where are we let's
start with do I have to worry about any
of those things right now any of those
grass Kyle Angus tilt or poetry I mean
if you don't have it I guess I wouldn't
necessarily worry about it it's one of
those things where if they start to pop
up you want to make sure you know how to
ID them so I guess in terms of worrying
about them I would just you know just be
sure I know how to ID them like goose
grass Kalinga and and poet rivey alice
those are again may be relatively new
weeds especially goose grass in Kalinga
so I would just be sure you know how to
identify them so that if they if they
pop up you can you can you know make the
appropriate adjustments because most of
our pre-emergents are going to be a lot
stronger on crabgrass and goose grass
and then Kalinga being a perennial weed
you know really we need to look at post
emergent surface size and some of the
cultural practices like you know
irrigation and drainage and eken and
you've got great resources the reason I
you know one of the things that's been
so great having a weed scientist in the
Northeast like you you really need you
and Randy are the
only two left sort of it seems to me and
you're really the only one doing a
hardcore turf stuff anymore so you are
saying a lot of these weeds or problems
or any of them I mean still crass isn't
invasive yes what point is Kyle Inga is
not invasive because landscape
professionals have at least some urgency
around invasives your resources help
with identification and control right
yes yeah for both goose grass crabgrass
and false crinkling and we do have some
fact sheets Rutgers Cooperative
Extension FAQ sheets that kind of go
through a little bit about how to
identify them and what to do to control
we haven't there is a stiltgrass fact
sheet as well from Rutgers that is
becoming more of a problem and it seems
like there's some still grass bio types
that are you know adapted to turf I used
to say you know well you know it may be
a long really long forest edges and tree
canopies and really shaded areas you see
stiltgrass where you don't know as much
or maybe you know it's kind of a you
know a nuisance but not a huge problem
but I've seen it in full Sun you know
bio types that seem like they're more
adapted to mowing than the stuff that's
in the forest the invasive it's in the
forest canopy so yeah that's that's
becoming a problem as well and that's
tricky to control because there aren't a
lot of labeled products and it's and
that one already terminated so that's
tricky you know that it germinates when
the soil temperatures are cooler than
crabgrass I've seen stiltgrass come up
already so if you haven't put out your
pre you know you're looking at post
emergent server sides which there's not
very many labeled about winter annuals
beautiful picture behind me is a chick
weed what is your winner I mean you know
a lot of guys again maybe a limited crew
spot treaty what are you telling people
about these kinds of weeds hanbit chick
weed things like that yeah I mean I
would be a good time to treat if you
want to treat but you know a lot of
these things are already flowering maybe
and putting out seed so you could just
you know choose to let them let them go
if that's an option and you understand
with the customer and say you know hey
these things are gonna die out here as
soon as it gets warm I mean henbit that
one's not gonna last much longer than a
month or two for most of us and the
chick will hang around a little longer
but unless it's really unless the
infestations are really severe I don't
know why winter annuals you know you
might be able to put that lower on the
priority list potentially but there are
lots of lots of good herbicides
available and they're pretty easy to
control as well so just depends on where
you're at are there any weeds we might
have to worry more about if we mow it
for inches that we didn't have to worry
about are there some that can get a
foothold like you know again a lot of
people have Bank grass in their lawn you
know a very difficult grass and also
very crappy the first thing that comes
to my mind what about other weeds that
might actually like not such frequent
mowing and yeah that's a good point I
really thought about that too much
I mean things like orchard grass could
be more of a problem you know there's
nobody's past your type weeds go a trip
right you'd see many more in a pasture
quackgrass and those those types of
things a lot of them are perennials
though I mean foxtails another one that
could get worse if we have higher mowing
it's always something right there's
gonna be some weed that's gonna find a
way to take advantage of any situation
so I mean in general you know you're
gonna have fewer problems if you mow
higher than if you mow lower but yeah
there could be in a few weeds like that
I don't think I would say those I mean
maybe a little bit more foxtail again an
orchard grass is kind of out right now
and it's so is poetry of those could
maybe get a little worse so along with
the bank grass but I think Bank wrasse
is more gonna be you know how wet is the
property how you know how where are
those poorly drained there is that might
compete better there okay all we got
questions muted muted there we go
so so first question from Walt you're
talking about hi I'm Owen Heights four
inches he's saying and he and his
experienced fine fescue especially if
it's shaded and thin if it gets to three
answers it'll start lodging so maybe you
could talk with Li Frank about certain
species that might not look so great
when you when you start get the higher
mowing heights or if they prevent some
long-term issues well I'll certainly
comment but I know Matt Elmore has a
pretty front-row seat to a lot of fine
fescues down there at Rutgers as well
I'll tell you certainly in thin shaded
areas where the canopies thin when you
raise the mowing height it's going to
have a very different appearance and it
is going to Lodge to be honest the only
thing that worries me about raising the
height of cut is places where there's a
predominant amount of older or
inexpensive rise and blue grasses that
are then going to go to flower and then
make the lawn stemmy
I worry about the lawns getting stemi
flower stalks in there as they dry as we
get later I actually see that as a much
bigger problem than the lodging because
because you know over time again if this
if it's uniform
I don't know that lodging is that big of
a deal I think a lot of people are going
to complain that they don't have mowers
that can manage the vegetation if we get
a growth surge that to me is the bigger
question and that's why I started out
with the you know the thing with Matt
about ok I want to feed it to get some
density if I've got a thin lawn but man
the last thing I want to do is put in on
this thing now if I can't work regularly
because I got a depleted staff or can't
get on the road so I think like with
weeds that we were talking about with
Matt about adaptations we're going to
make and you know weed may get an
advantage and we're just going to have
to be able to communicate it I think the
message is everybody is going to if
you're doing this smartly in my mind
they're going to notice changes in their
landscape
I want Matt for you to tell me at this
point all things consider how much
should I worry about weeds and should I
suit no worry about mowing and keeping
people out of there and you know you've
got time and this is we got a we don't
we go till July August it's a different
deal but a couple of months don't be
trigger fingered here yeah yeah and I
agree I think if it hopefully it's just
a couple months and don't do anything
crazy they
having done war you know don't decide
well I'm gonna you know put out
pre-emergent at 2 2 X or I'm gonna try
this new herbicide I haven't used or I'm
gonna you know I think increasing the
mowing height slightly you know just do
everything in small steps and no no no
big you know crazy changes because I
don't you know and even if you get a bad
crabgrass infestation if this goes on I
mean you can always recede in the fall
and you know a reset everything so if
the crabgrass comes up and we come back
in August and it hasn't flowered we've
got widespread turf renovation going on
yeah so yeah I think that that would be
a good that's a good point don't get
trigger-happy and and start
experimenting with on large properties
or large scale with things that yeah you
know you're not sure about or you
haven't done before so yeah we got a
great one from yeah I got one more from
Dan shy a really good question and we've
talked with this talk with Dan about
this in the past but he says them if you
had a long and a routine program of
annual pre-emergent multiple annual
fertilizations herbicide applications
shouldn't church stands be somewhat
resilient to missing a spring app
especially if combined with higher
mowing height so and I think this gets
into a little bit of the weed seed bank
historical management kind of questions
here benefits from the two things we're
talking about maybe a little bit of
increased density higher mowing height
and I guess Matt the question is to you
don't do you think many well-maintained
previously well-maintained stands that
you've had for a long time 15 20 year
old lawns what if you miss all the
spring apps how bad is it you think it's
likely to get yeah if you've got a
well-maintained lawn you might not be so
bad now typically I it's a little bit of
a gamble because if you say if you've
been putting pre-emergents on every year
you still may have a little bit of a
seed bank that you don't know about
because you've been applying freeze and
then if you decide not to
make that application this year and then
we get you know you get into a labor
shortage and you can't get to the
property you might get behind so it's a
bit of a gamble but definitely it
wouldn't be the craziest thing you know
typically you if you wanted to see if
you wanted to you know try to back off
the pre this year you typically want to
do it in a year where you could you knew
you could get back to the property if
progress slips through to make an
application before we get to August and
it's too late but you know if you want
to maybe take a bit of a gamble on some
some properties where you've had good
turf density over the years do it I know
times are tough my business is suffering
too we've done a pretty good job here we
think we can get by with this this year
and yeah right and maybe you tell them
you to communicate that maybe we're
gonna save you an application hours
that's it's all about communication
because crabgrass is not the end of the
world and that's a great way to end now
that we've seen his beautiful daughter
Carl there any more questions just
warning I think it may be a ties in
there Gary's asking about tenacity
residual for crabgrass does that have
some post emergence I guess we can see
it in to has a really short window for
pre-and yeah yeah I have some some
decent post emergence activity as long
as where the plants are maybe maybe one
or two Taylor crabgrass plants not much
bigger than that and the residual is
yeah not not too long maybe a few weeks
in the middle of the summer middle of
the spring a great option though if
you've seen it in the fall or if you're
gonna see this spring or something so
but it is a potential option if you know
if you get out there if we can't get out
there till May or something like that
and so if Gary I'm sure Gary no Gary
smart thinking about this okay these
guys just said what if I can't
until July I got crabgrass well if it's
one to two tiller so we're gonna monitor
this maybe if we're locked down that
will come back and his daughter will
join us again and we'll say okay now
you're here if you can get in now you
can go with tenacity knock down what's
there cut it back and see it into it and
you're home free how is the nasty
pre-owned annual bluegrass it it's it's
pretty good I mean it's really the only
thing it's actually labeled for
pre-emergents annual bluegrass control
there's there's a lot of work looking at
it for post emergence it's not labeled
there it's it's it is labeled it depends
on the density of the annual bluegrass
seed bank now sometimes it works very
well I'd say either way you're gonna
need using it for pre-emergents annual
bluegrass control of a fall shooting you
don't want to plan on two or three
applications you know one at seeding and
then one four weeks later and then maybe
even another one after that so it's a
it's a good option yeah for sure it and
and it's that's really you're looking at
a pre emergence as a pre-emergent
herbicide tenacity is best used for
annual bluegrass maybe more so than
crabgrass I'd only use it for crabgrass
if I'm spring seeding because that's
your only option really cuz two persons
not really renowned too much anymore but
two percent is a good option as well for
in the spring not gonna be good friend
you'll bluegrass in the fall all right
well we not got all the questions Frank
so I think we'll wrap it up there today
Matt thanks again for production by Matt
thanks thanks to your family as well I
know your wife is a health care worker
we hope to stay safe and you know thanks
for your family for all that again
everybody thanks for joining
we'll be right back here next week
Friday 10:00 a.m.
seemly and of course you'll be able to
find this on a recording as well thanks
everybody thanks you too they save
everybody this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu